The Google Data Center in Dublin, Ireland.
The scale of what we do here can be kind of crazy.
Millions of searches a day goes through those machines.
That's why they're very loud and they produce lots of heat.
That means they're constantly working, constantly answering your queries.
And so how do we really store the web, so to speak?
The way to think about it is we take the internet, download it,...
...index it, and chop it into small pieces, and then each server has a small piece.
All of the servers for that data center work together...
...to each search their little part of the internet.
And it literally takes millions of servers and hard drives...
...to be able to support the world's websites.
So each of these data centers has a complete copy of the web.
So if you're in France or if you're in South Africa, you're not sending...
...a query that goes through the wires on underwater cables...
...and comes from Mountain View, asks that question, then we send it back.
That's just not possible.
That's never going to work as a solution that's fast.
How it actually works is you go into Google and you type in a search,..
...then we direct your query to the data center that is closest.
And so that's actually the reason why we have data centers everywhere,...
...because we want to be close to the users that we're serving.
Because that's the only way to get you the most accurate response as fast as possible.